Another situation in which nested loops often arise is image editing. In the
past we've traversed the pixels of an image in a single loop going a row at a
time. But there are many situations when it makes more sense to make separate
loops for the rows and columns. For example suppose that we want to have this
effect where we hide all of the pixels that are outside the circle. In this
case, you will want to know what the x and y position of the pixels are. Given
values for x and y, you can get a pixel by calling a method called getColorAt
and similarly there's a setColorAt that let's you set the color at an x and y
location. To get this effect then, we will want to loop through all of the
possible x's and all of the possible y's with coordinates x, y and see how
close it is to the center point. If this distance is less than the radius of
the circle, then we want to leave the pixel untouched. But for a point out
here, where the distance is greater than the radius, we want to color this
point black by calling setColorAt. Here's the outline of the program. Two
nested loops for all values of x and y. Compute the distance. The problem gives
you the general formula for computing that and then go ahead and do the
coloring.